KORY JEFFREY: Greetings,
everyone, and welcome.
We are on site at Founder
World in San Francisco.
Joining me in the studio is Lisa
Fetterman, the CEO of Nomiku,
who has a hardware and
software solution that
is changing the world
for the food industry.
[LAUGHING]
Tell us a little bit about it.
LISA FETTERMAN: So Nomiku is
the first of our home sous
vide immersion circulator.
And we have a Wi-Fi one
coming out this November
that you can use your
app on your phone,
for Android or iOS
or Windows phone,
where it controls your machine.
And you can cook with one tap.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
So for those who don't know, can
you explain what sous vide is?
LISA FETTERMAN: Yes.
KORY JEFFREY: Yes.
Sous vide is a relatively
new thing that's come about.
But it's been used for
decades by top chefs
all around the world.
And now, top chefs use
my machine-- [INAUDIBLE]
in Madison Park, Saison,
Restaurant at Meadowood.
And what it does is that it
controls water and circulates
it to a very
precise temperature.
What you do is put
your food inside of bag
and then drop it into
the water, walk away.
When you come back, you
have a world class meal.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So what's the
price point for something
like that, typically?
LISA FETTERMAN: $199.
It used to be
thousands of dollars.
I remember working for
Jean-Georges and Mario Batali.
And we would have this
huge, hulking piece
of laboratory equipment that
was thousands of dollars.
And we would cook a lot
of our components in it.
And I was like, why?
When you took food
out of there, it
was like eating heavenly food.
You know how food
is perfect on TV?
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, yeah.
LISA FETTERMAN: This
is how they do it.
KORY JEFFREY: Really?
So how long does it take to cook
something using that method?
LISA FETTERMAN:
It really ranges,
depending on what you cook.
Like, fish is 20 minutes.
KORY JEFFREY: OK.
LISA FETTERMAN:
Steak is an hour.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
LISA FETTERMAN:
Sometimes, there's
short ribs that are 48 hours.
So you put that in there, and
then you just go to sleep.
KORY JEFFREY: And
then you wake up,
and then you go to sleep again.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: So you've recently
had a whole bunch of accolades,
including the White House,
we were talking about?
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah.
I'm a White House honored maker.
That's how we got our start,
from the Maker Revolution.
We traveled, actually, across
the United States teaching
people how to make their own DIY
open source sous vide machines.
Our code is still up on Eagle.
We have our CAD files
up, whatever people want.
They can make their
own sous vide machine.
KORY JEFFREY: Great.
LISA FETTERMAN:
That's our start.
And this year, I'm also
a Forbes 30 Under 30
and Zagat 30 Under 30
for the innovation.
KORY JEFFREY: Wow.
LISA FETTERMAN: So thank you--
thank you, the media gods.
KORY JEFFREY: It's a lot of
momentum-- lot of momentum.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah,
a lot of momentum,
because this is a way of cooking
that everybody has been waiting
for, myself included.
And I couldn't believe it
hadn't even been done before.
It's like modern art.
It's like, oh, you just control
the temperature very precisely?
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah?
LISA FETTERMAN: My
kid could do that.
You know what I'm saying?
KORY JEFFREY: Sure.
LISA FETTERMAN: It
was just too obvious,
because ever since
the dawn of fire,
we've been trying to control it.
And if you think
about chefs, what they
do-- they're not the
controllers of the ingredients.
That's the farmers.
What they do in the
kitchen is to control heat.
And now, you can control heat
to 0.1 degrees Celsius, that's
completely revolutionary
to how you can cook.
KORY JEFFREY: Great.
And so what's the
market share like?
LISA FETTERMAN: The
market share-- well,
great thing you asked,
because Unilever, Nestle,
and Campbell-- they all lose $16
billion a year in market share
to people like me
who cook food the way
that people really, really
want to eat it-- perfectly.
So a big thing that they
lose out on is frozen food.
KORY JEFFREY: OK.
LISA FETTERMAN: And
that's packaged food.
And what we do is that we
have-- we have packaged food
that we sell.
Yeah.
We have it in beta
right now with BuyRIGHT.
All you have to do
is go to our website,
and then we ship it
right to your door.
You drop it in the water,
and then walk away.
It's just like microwaved food,
except it becomes the freaking
centerpiece of your meal.
KORY JEFFREY: Does it lose
any nutritional value?
LISA FETTERMAN: That's
right, because nothing cooks
at above 100 degrees Celsius.
At 57 degrees Celsius,
the fat and the collagen
melt into the muscle of a steak.
Effectively, you can make a NY
strip steak taste like ragout.
It's so good.
Magic happens.
KORY JEFFREY: You're
making me hungry.
LISA FETTERMAN: Oh, good.
Oh, good.
You can come eat.
Come eat at Namiku.
KORY JEFFREY: So you're
also a speaker here today.
You have a booth.
How did the speaking session go?
LISA FETTERMAN: The speaking
session was off the chain.
There are so many people here.
KORY JEFFREY: There are.
There's a lot.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah,
so it was really
fun to speak in front
of a big audience.
KORY JEFFREY: So what
was your message?
What were you trying
to talk about?
LISA FETTERMAN: The message
was the connection between food
and everything in our lives.
People treat food
like, oh, whatever.
They treat it as some
kind of soft, soft thing.
But it's like hard.
It's real freaking money.
And also, you put in
your body every day.
KORY JEFFREY: Captive audience.
LISA FETTERMAN: The experience--
you have to have it.
KORY JEFFREY: So what
drew you to this event?
LISA FETTERMAN:
This event-- I just
love that there was gonna
be like smart people here.
I don't have to explain
what sous vide is
to every single person.
And also, a lot of cool people--
like Tim Draper was here,
Danielle Fong, Hiba,
Hammoud-- these people
that I watched from
afar build their stuff.
I'm like, oh, how you do that?
KORY JEFFREY: That's cool.
LISA FETTERMAN: So that's
why it was exciting.
KORY JEFFREY: And
so obviously, you're
a big fan of technology,
food technology.
Is there anything
else in the landscape
that kind of gets you excited
from a technology perspective?
LISA FETTERMAN: From a
technology perspective,
I love all things hardware.
So there's this thing
called Ever Purse.
They just partnered
with Kate Spade.
And what they did is that they
made this cute little bag,
you drop your phone in,
and then it charges it.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's pretty cool.
LISA FETTERMAN: Boosh.
I need that.
I never charge my phone.
KORY JEFFREY: Right.
That's really clever, actually.
LISA FETTERMAN: Yeah, I love it.
KORY JEFFREY: Very cool.
And do you have a favorite
Google technology?
LISA FETTERMAN: A
favorite Goog-- oh, Goog.
Well, I love Gmail-- no doy.
Holler at Paul Buchheit.
You know what I'm saying?
Gmail-- I mean, how could-- I
use it for my business, too.
lisa@nomiku.com, that
goes through Gmail.
I can't believe I've been
using it for years now.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah, it's
a really good product.
LISA FETTERMAN: I probably
use a lot of Google stuff
that I don't even
know it's Google.
KORY JEFFREY: That
is probably true,
which is part of
the point, right?
LISA FETTERMAN: Yes.
Oh, actually, you know what?
One thing that I
really do notice
that I insist on when
I'm in a rideshare,
whether it's Lyft
or Uber, I'm like,
can you please use Google Maps?
For god's sake, use Google Maps.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah,
I do too, actually.
That's true.
LISA FETTERMAN: Word.
KORY JEFFREY: Well, thank
you very much for joining me.
LISA FETTERMAN: Thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you for joining me.
This has been on site at
Founder World San Francisco.